let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
taco
tuesday
primaries primaries primaries
if you want your outrage to count
go
[ __ ]
vote
go [ __ ] vote if you want your outrage
to count
that is what it's all about is making
your outrage
about these fascist count and how we do
that is go [ __ ] king vote
go [ __ ] vote go [ __ ] vote go
[ __ ] vote and don't just go mark your
ballot make sure all your friends and
your family
who are tired
of these republican fascists taking away
our liberties
make sure they go [ __ ] vote
and you say tony but it's only a primary
yes
but it is it is important to have your
voice
heard in every
single election
every one of them regardless
rather it's a primary a midterm a
general
for the [ __ ] dog catcher
you don't want your dogs to be
caught up with a bunch of fascists do
you
we can't have fascist dog catchers we
can't have fascists congress people we
can't have fascist governors we must
[ __ ]
vote and we must participate
in the vote and boy speaking of
participation do we have
so many people here so many new
listeners here at the tony michaels
podcast you know we broadcast live
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and now simulcasting from the
mind as touch facebook page
for your enjoyment your pleasure your
cathartic release
to give these fascists what for and boy
do i have some video of a fascist a
cristofascist i would love to show you
i'm going to show you this one today
holy
[ __ ]
and i say that with the most amount of
irony i possibly can and it is a pun
holy [ __ ]
jesus christ this guy
you've heard of this grey glock
character i'm going to show you
whoo
baby
we have to go vote so people like him
are not in control of anything
this guy needs a straight jacket
whoosh padded cell
this guy needs he's got
he's got jesus confused with someone
else
like he thinks he thinks jesus
was the leader of nazi germany at some
point or something i mean seriously this
guy has lost his [ __ ] marbles
he's lost his marbles his marbles packed
their [ __ ] and left
welcome everyone welcome all the new
listeners
we have so many people watching out
there on youtube so many people watching
out there on facebook we have nolan
farron
cynthia amanda is here
midas robin kathy is here valerie's here
dude what the [ __ ] for is here nancy is
here mj good morning jennifer ron from
facebook
janie from facebook
david
curtis lisa from facebook cindy from
facebook jill
there's just so many new listeners i
can't even hardly keep up
and you guys engage and participate and
chat
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel if you're over on
the books of face
if you're watching from the mind as
touch facebook page make sure to hit
that link at the top to our youtube
channel you do not want to miss any
videos that we may publish over here on
the youtube channel and you definitely
want to come over at least once a week
and participate in the super chat
you don't have to throw a super chat or
super sticker but you gotta come over
here to the youtube chat
it's all fun over here
it's fun over on the facebook chat too
so come over to the youtube channel
subscribe and if you're on facebook
follow us on the midas touch facebook
page and you can follow me on facebook
as well i have a facebook page
just go to the tony michaels type in
tony michaels podcast go to the
tonymichaels.com you'll find all the
links
there
today's primary day
primary day in several states
i believe that probably the one of the
most important primary races obviously
is going to be
the senate races in pennsylvania but
also a race to watch
is the tree puncher madison cawthorne
askwatch as i call him some people call
him hitler i do not call him hitler i
think that's
i think that's kind of offensive
so i would never call him sittler i
would never intentionally say that he
was hitler never intentionally
only offhandedly
i i like i like the nickname for madison
cothor in his ass squatch that you know
the disappointing thing about madison
cawthorne here is when he does lose this
primary
if he gets his ass kicked his hairy ass
crack kicked in this in this primary
he will fade off into the distance and
we will we will probably never
we will probably never hear from
askwatch
again
all darn the luck
wouldn't you [ __ ] know it that would
just be disappointing wouldn't it
if we never heard from the tree punching
ass squatch
again
madison gothorn if he gets his hairy
crack kicked
in the primary
i don't know i'm i i mean
not making predictions i mean i guess i
guess i would try to make a prediction
in that primary but the problem is in
that primary we're trading one [ __ ] box
for another in some of these republican
primaries like the primary in
pennsylvania it doesn't matter which
[ __ ] republican you choose
they all got their cheeto dust knee pads
on they're all ready to be sycophants
for trump rather it's this barnette
this proud boy trump humping fool
he was that january 6th he tried to
storm the capital
with the proud boys the whites the white
supremacist of the proud boys whether
it's her
or it's dr oz that crazy [ __ ]
what's the difference
what's the difference really
you tell me i [ __ ] i don't know
i mean how can we say one's better than
the other like we don't want any of
these [ __ ] fascists are these
capitulators
in office anywhere
so if you're in a republican primary and
you're trying to choose
good [ __ ] luck
looks like a lot of folks are gonna vote
for fetterman
that's some for lamb but i mean you know
i i i believe that in the pennsylvania
primary the most important part
is to have
a democrat that is going to throw
punches like that's the important part i
mean i you know
you may have your preference there and
pennsylvanians
should have their preference and they
should definitely go vote in the primary
for their preference of who they think
can throw the toughest punch
because believe you me if you think
these these these republicans in
pennsylvania whoever wins whatever crazy
wins the primary there
on the gqp side
on the kid diddler side i mean i you
know
they're gonna try to throw punches
they're gonna lie they're gonna cheat
they're gonna steal
you know that for sure i mean they're
sick of fanning for donald trump why
wouldn't they
i wouldn't be surprised if they filed
bankruptcy three times before they get
to the midterm
i i mean is it would it be surprising no
now it wouldn't be surprising
so my my guess is
is that maybe we should want the uh
the proud boys sycophant
over dr oz i mean normalizing this
[ __ ] fool dr oz
has been a fraud on this country just
like normalizing dr phil and
dr rand paul and all these fake ass
doctors
since when can you just go get a [ __ ]
fake license to be a goddamn doctor
and then not only that try to run for
[ __ ] senate
what in the actual [ __ ]
so go vote go vote go vote
now is the time now right now today is
the time if you're in these states for
primaries and we're going to go through
this a little bit today
which states are available
to go vote in a primary now is the time
to go make your outrage count you know
that we stay pissed here we have
strategic outrage
now is the time to make that outrage
count literally they're gonna count your
outrage so go
[ __ ] vote and don't just vote
talk to your friends your neighbors if
they can't get there if they need a ride
help them out
give someone a ride to the polls if they
want to vote but they can't get there
super important right now that we make a
statement even if it's a primary
democrats do this stuff so too often
like oh well it doesn't really matter i
mean
it's just i'm voting for one democrat
over the other well i don't know if you
vote for the shitty one the shitty one
gets in
and it can't throw enough [ __ ]
punches
at the goddamn fascist
then the fascists might win
so yeah it's [ __ ] really important
every single one of these elections is
the most important one
i'm gonna be saying that
right here into this microphone this
midterm is the most important election
of your life and as soon as it's over as
soon as the ballots are counted and it's
finalized and certified and stuffed away
and we have the new congress the new
senate new governors new state
legislators
the next election will be the most
important one of your lifetime because
these fascists are not going to quit
they're not going to stop they're going
to be like okay you got us you won we're
just going to stop being fascist now
no
no
hatred don't stop
it doesn't stop
they're not gonna just crawl back
underneath their rocks at this point we
it's proven that
joe biden beat donald trump by 8 million
votes
and we still got these [ __ ]
yelling and screaming carrying nazi
flags down at disneyland
saying you passing bills where you can't
say gay
passing bills to where they can marry
children passing bills where they take
the consent of parents away from their
children passing bills
to take away women's litter liberty of
their bodily autonomy passing bills to
to outlaw contraception
they're gonna try to pass bills to make
sure certain people don't get married to
who they love
you think they're just gonna stop
nope
it is up to us to keep fighting every
single [ __ ] minute of the day
against this nonsense
because they're not gonna quit
i'll give you evidence of it of tucker
carlson last night
laying laying the blame and being the
victim oh
you you lefties on twitter are blaming
me
for the maga king mass shooter in
buffalo well it's not me and i went and
i made sure to go look at his manifesto
immediately i mean tucker carlson was
digging for ideas for his show and the
manifesto
i'm sure
probably he was probably he probably
seeked out this manifesto maybe this
guy's a good writer i don't know hell
maybe we can use some of his ideas for
our show
we're gonna watch some video from tucker
tucker carlson [ __ ]
fish dickheaded [ __ ]
so we're gonna watch some video from
that son of a [ __ ] trying to justify
why his language and why his talk did
not stoke the fear and the lies and the
delusion of this white supremacist when
he's talking about replacement theory
white replacement theory
oh jesus which again
crt not [ __ ] voodoo wrt [ __ ]
voodoo it's all [ __ ] voodoo with
these
boneheads [ __ ] and boneheads
let's see what else is in the news today
we have some other stuff in the news
other than the primaries it looks like
we have ufos in the news um we have
official congressional hearings for the
first time in like 100 years i don't
know some since the 1960s it's the first
time they've done
congressional hearings on ufos and and
what what is funny to me and and i know
the q anon conspiracy theorists are
gonna latch onto this [ __ ]
because this morning ufos was trending
number one
on twitter
ufos unidentified flying object right we
all know that's what ufo stand for
but they soon switched they soon
switched
to unidentified aerial phenomenon to be
trending the uap not the ufo
because they don't want uh you know what
to get confused
twitter we we're watching you of course
taco tuesday's trending maybe we should
ask our co-host gabe you know gabe is a
burrito and taco
aficionado maybe we'll see what
what gabe will be having for taco
tuesday this week now the trumps is
trending
dan crenshaw is trending as well because
tucker carlson
is butt hurt that dan crenshaw might
leak the truth out of his eye patch
well and a lot of people are upset that
tucker carlson called him eye patch
mccain i think that's a great nickname
tucker
uh ball state is trending i'm not
exactly sure why jordan peterson is
trending probably because he tans his
balls and he doesn't know what beauty
actually is uh pfizer kovet is trending
i'm not sure why i haven't been in that
thread yet and the lgbtqi
is trending as well there's some other
stuff turning but i i i couldn't fit it
all in
the unidentified aerial phenomenon was
really long on the twitter list
so it takes up characters so here's what
happens in the morning because someone
was messaging oh my god i don't see the
i don't see the the art on the youtube
page are you guys okay we are always
okay over here every single morning you
can count on us to be here noon eastern
11 central nine pacific every single
weekday youtube twitter twitch and
simone cast from the midas touch
facebook page there was uh about a month
ago i lost my voice on a friday i did
two hours two hours without a voice
i'm dedicated folks i'm committed and
i'm gonna be here even if i'm just
sitting here shaking my head into the
microphone
i will be here
every single weekday two hours
monday
through friday but here's what happens
so in the morning we're looking at
twitter right we're trying to figure out
what's trending what the news is
because we try to bring you guys our
commentary on the live events that are
happening right [ __ ] now right now we
try to bring you the the live commentary
that's the whole point of the show
if you want some strategic outrage into
a microphone and yelling screaming into
some microphone some cathartic therapy
as it were
this is the place
because we will definitely give you
cathartic therapy on the current events
because we follow the current events
here on the tony michaels podcast with
the [ __ ] list roundup you guys know the
[ __ ] list roundup every single day we go
through the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends
so i look at the trends gabe's looking
at the trends we're trying to figure out
what's the story of the day most the
time we're wrong because you know how
these stories last about five [ __ ]
seconds
but we're trying to figure out what the
story of the day is he's trying to
develop art do the whole art thing
you know gabe sanchez is not only just a
taco and burrito enthusiast he's also
the art department here at the tony
michaels podcast he's our designer
so he's working on that
and that takes a bit sometimes to pull
images and throw it on the the thumbnail
the beautiful thumbnails do you guys
like the thumbnails that he makes
and make sure make sure to give gabe
some love
on twitter and youtube about the
thumbnails that he's been making he's
been doing a wonderful job
so
but here's the thing if you go just
subscribe to the youtube channel we will
be here every single every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific uh don't
again don't forget to subscribe to the
youtube channel that is vitally
important and you might even i don't
know if you guys know this but you can
be a member
of the youtube channel now so you can go
be a member if you would like or you can
participate in the super chat also go
follow us on twitter at tonymichaelspod
that's where our broadcasts uh
are at every single weekday over on
twitter at tonymichael's pod
so and also the announcement the show
announcement comes out about 15 10 or 15
minutes before the show every single day
for the youtube link
and then after the show here's what we
do
we take the audio we cut it we download
it we upload it
to the interwebs to your favorite
directory apple spotify google so go
download every single episode
there
every single episode there boy do we
have a lot of tweety tweets and trendy
trends to get to today
i think gabe's gonna be joining us here
in just a minute but let's do this
let's get to the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends
get to the [ __ ] list
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the tony michaels podcast we have
reached the part of the show where we
round up all the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends uh helen points out a good
a good
a good fact 10 o'clock mountain time
i used to just say the eastern and
yeah
the eastern and
central time and then i added pacific
at 10 o'clock mountain 10 o'clock
mountain time
every single week as well mj says a
member what am i missing
uh yeah we have we have a membership
thing so we have a patreon
um that you can go join but you can also
join the the youtube members maybe we'll
talk more about that in the next week or
two give you guys some information on
the members what we'll be doing for you
guys as far as members go if you become
a member of the youtube what that would
mean
you probably have early access to videos
um and maybe even have exclusive videos
maybe have some maybe you have some
exclusive live streams
so
we will we will go through that
in the next few weeks the next few weeks
speaking of the next few weeks you guys
know
it looks like this week we're gonna get
more
information
on the schedule of the january 6 select
committee hearings the public hearings
that they're going to have in june
so
hopefully we'll be able to start develop
a schedule for you guys of how we're
going to live stream that and where and
when and all that kind of good stuff who
will be joining us for those live
streams
we do plan on um live streaming and
partner you know we're partners with
midas touch so i think we will be uh
streaming with them um so we'll try to
get you where we're going to be in the
schedule the thing though is it's really
hard because we don't actually know
what the what the
total
uh
schedule is we're not sure the timing
who's going to be where and when like
are they going to be during the day or
some of the evening it seems like it's
going to be a mixed bag of the schedule
which we're going to try to make sure
that we get plenty of commentary not
just for me and gabe but um we have kfa
popock from legal af um and possibly the
mizellas brothers from midas touch uh
i i've talked to lee mcgowan politics
girl it looks like she may be coming and
giving us commentary so i'm i'm hoping
that we can get some good folks here
throughout those hearings to give you
guys their thoughts their commentary
live on a live stream and again i'm not
sure exactly the plan but we'd like to
have two different live streams one
where we're giving commentary one where
we're not so one is just the feed it's
just you seeing what the world is seeing
if you don't want to listen to us
talking over the hearing now and then
um but we all but we'll also have the
commentary one uh so we'll be producing
both at the same time we'll also be
doing the show at the same time so
that's gonna be a little weird and
difficult but we'll get through this
we'll make it through we'll figure it
out we'll let you know the schedule as
it comes up for those hearings
so that's important um someone's asking
here about oh yes another announcement i
think we're gonna have the dakota adams
the estranged son of the oath keepers i
think we're gonna have the
uh interview ready tomorrow to air so
tomorrow uh we'll probably be going
through a lot of these primary races and
the results of those races and then also
also we'll be airing an interview that
we've done over the weekend with dakota
adams the estranged son of the oath
keepers we've done another updated
interview with some of the new
news that has come out some of the new
plea deals and what his thoughts are on
stuart rhodes
and the oath keepers and some of the
legal trouble that they're in
so watch tomorrow we should have that
interview ready tomorrow for you to air
let's get to the tweety tweets and
trendy trends let's go to the timeline
here
i told you i have a lot of video that i
wanna that i wanna go through um
but here is uh here's my main tweet of
the day
i think if you're out there in these
states that are gonna be voting this is
definitely where you should
have your outrage it's time to make your
outrage count go [ __ ] vote
go [ __ ] vote go [ __ ] vote
very important minus touch says
if there is a primary oh it did it by
zoom
if there is a primary election in your
state today make sure you vote to save
democracy we all need to get off the
sidelines and let our both voices
be heard speaking of being heard let's
see if gabe sanchez has his microphone
working this morning gabe can we hear
you
[Laughter]
my transitions are are getting better
and better every single day gabe every
single day
um
yeah how how are you this morning gabe
the people were worried about you this
morning you know i i know you guys are
very uh
yeah i mean they were like where's
where's the goddamn thumbnail gabe
they're right here they were
you got hair in your water yeah i don't
i think i think so it was something
something came out and that was weird
it was madison gothard at your house
last night ask watch was he i don't know
why did you look at the bed did you look
at the bed
i don't know
if everyone doesn't know gabe gabe gabe
broadcast um from his sanctuary his um
where all the where all the uh yeah the
action happens yeah you know
but he looked over at the bed when i
said ask watch he was he's really what
where was he where was he
keep it down keep it down
put put your put your ass ass hawk away
put your hands i know i know him him and
his cousin
yeah well you know they came they came
in last night and my dog's like what the
[ __ ] is going on you know oh oh so
that's you got here all over the place
yeah it's like all over in your water
yeah i know really oh that was weird
anyway
uh
what am i doing how am i doing i'm good
i just uh i just put a clip to actually
we could play the clip i just put a clip
together of uh
2018 tucker carlson in 2022 tucker oh
really yeah that would be beautiful did
you did you post it on twitter i was
literally about to but i'll play it here
as a promoter oh my gosh exclusive
exclusive gabe sanchez
cut and clip where how are you going to
do this you're going to send me a link
are you going to know i'm just going to
i'm just going to
i'm just going to put it up here we're
gonna do it live baby we'll do it live
live
do it live do it live
do it live
have you guys ever you guys probably you
know that we're referring to the uh
um what what's what what the uh bill oh
yeah riley
what does it mean to play it off what
what the [ __ ] does that mean to play it
off is that right [ __ ] it we'll do it
live we'll do it live we'll do it live
that's what we do here we do it live
yeah okay two hours a day am i playing
this video this is the one yeah this is
this is tucker carlson the flip flopper
the flip let's just do clips
well in the past two years the
democratic party has outsourced much of
its political philosophy to the late
night tv shows they haven't closed the
think tanks here in dc but they don't
pay any attention
they pay attention to saturday night
live it's not as funny as it used to be
but it does know a lot about what the
left now believes here for example is
their final pitch for the 2018 midterms
republicans
are disgusting some of them were even
wounded in wars you may be surprised to
hear he's a congress
oh i thought it was a sound bite but
it's not you're seeing on the screen
though part of saturday night live texas
congressional candidate dan crenshaw
lost an eye to an ied in afghanistan on
saturday actor pete davidson mocked him
as one of the quote really gross people
running for office this year he said
added i'm sorry i know he lost his eye
in war or whatever
yeah so that's their position and
they're not hiding it anymore useful for
you to know
that's it for us tonight we're out of
time sadly that hour went quick we'll be
back every week night 8 pm the show that
is the sworn and sincere enemy of lying
pomposity smugness the more i think
about it it takes a lot of gall for eye
patch mccain to attack moms who are
worried about baby formula as quote
that's one of the most outrageous things
i think i've ever heard now that i'm
thinking about i mean why not just
answer the question why why the attacks
what does that tell you
so
example november very interesting
2018
tucker carlson goes on the defensive and
says oh pete davidson is is a is a
terrible person for making fun of dan
crenshaw the joke was he reminds him of
uh of a um
a hit man from a porno that was the joke
right that that was that was that was
pete davis pete davidson went through a
list on weekend update and was talking
about different candidates that were
running for the republican party in the
primaries and when dan crenshaw came up
he said oh reminds me of a hitman from a
porno that's what he said
let's be fair here let's be fair here he
definitely did look like a hit man oh
yeah
i mean
the joke isn't that far off i mean right
so
you have uh tucker carlson getting all
butt hurt and saying that snl is uh is
making him
uh making fun of him and then you get
tucker cross in 2022 where he's like oh
he's eye patch mccain so you know just
to go to show you that tucker carls is
not who he says he is he doesn't believe
what you all think he believes in he
will say what he says because it's an
entertainment show it is not news
and once again tucker carlson flip-flops
more than i don't know mitch mcconnell
hmm
surely tucker carlson doesn't have
flip-flopping views and i bet i would
almost bet that cr dan crenshaw if you
looked at enough clip which i'm going to
have one right here um also also doesn't
have flip-flopping views
um then crenshaw seems to be very woke
these days uh as as tucker carlson was
saying let's go in fighting yeah let's
listen there's some bad arguments too
people are saying well we can't put baby
formula on our shelves but we're sending
money to ukrainians
and my response to that is you know how
much baby formula you can buy with 40
billion dollars none
none because it's not a money issue it's
a manufacturing issue
oh dan crenshaw and you're facts
you know i've always said what
i've always said about dan grindel
get get a [ __ ] glass eye would you
please this is really done with the eye
patch you're trying to look cool you're
trying to look tough and i actually i'm
with tucker here i actually think eye
patch mccain is not it's not that bad of
a nickname i mean frankly if you know if
you're gonna if you're gonna break away
from tucker and say is it is it
is it a great nickname but the hypocrisy
here on both sides
is just [ __ ] gross um
i mean dan crenshaw obviously he's
telling the truth about the baby formula
story because that's the true story is
you can't buy something that doesn't
exist right like there's no buying
there's no buying
a formula that you can't manufacture
and money isn't going to make it
manufacture even more because he goes on
in this clip which i'm not going to play
he goes on in this clip to continue to
talk about
how
the reason why we have a formula
shortage is because it's a supply chain
because there's a factory shut down and
the fda has to get this factory back
running like that's the whole point
and dan crenshaw
i think dan crenshaw's making a very uh
a very
good political calculation here that the
country
is not going to be backing putin and
they're not going to be backing
politicians that back putin do you agree
with that do you think and that's why
tucker's pissed at him and that's why he
has tulsi gabbard on who is a russian
asset for all intents and purposes yeah
to sycophant for putin against putin's
enemy which is dan crenshaw who tells
the truth that he's a murderous [ __ ]
dictator i mean if you're against putin
you're against tucker
i think that's what it is
if you say anything that goes against
what tucker carlson is preaching right
if you catch him on the wrong side of
the bed
that wasn't an innuendo about madison
cawthorne uh if you catch him on the
wrong side of the bed
tucker carlson is going to come after
you because putin says
you know i'm going to release my hounds
and obviously tucker carlson is you know
putin tv it is it is russian tv it is
propaganda so of course he's going to
bring people on like tulsi gabbard and
and try to push her narrative and her
her propaganda and go against anyone who
says anything that is against
what the show is is trying to to
advocate for or advocate against
whatever it might be now i will say the
the nickname eye patch mccain though
is a little off
for tucker and the reason why is because
mccain definitely wasn't a poo putin
sycophant and and mccain would be the
first one that to tell uh tucker to go
to [ __ ] hell right and that and that
probably is why tucker hates mccain
hates crenshaw now um he loves dulce
gabbard obviously he's had her on his
show like six times the last two weeks
oh yeah and he's like yeah you're going
to talk putin let's talk putin let me do
that let's do that who knows a putin
puppet better than another putin puppet
right that's true it's true the mirrors
the mirrors the mirrors are clear there
and you can see right through them
okay so
so uh everyone is is talking about a
troll that's in the chat we did get rid
of him because of the [ __ ] that he says
i want to be clear about something with
the trolls you you hate watchers and
trolls are welcome here but you start
saying racist [ __ ] and you start saying
specific stuff about people in the chat
i will [ __ ] get rid of you i will
bounce you if you're saying vile [ __ ] to
specific people in the chat yeah you're
welcome you are welcome you are more
than welcome to say almost anything you
want about me and gabe
and and you but as as long as you're
being not racist not bigoted and you're
not saying [ __ ] about people in the chat
you are welcome to stay you are welcome
to hate watching but i will [ __ ]
bounce you
if you're saying buy all [ __ ] about the
other chat i don't care who it is i
don't care if it's another [ __ ] troll
so i just want to be clear about that so
uh everyone can rest assure
that the troll
has been bounced until i get another
[ __ ] sign yeah because they'll be
back don't worry they'll be back they
love to hate us oh you block me you you
suppress my thought my mom my voice
ah this is the same i think that was the
same troll that the other day they were
saying something like yesterday
yesterday
yesterday he came at us and said that um
we were we were trying to we were
fascists we were trying to suppress the
voice whatever and we literally said on
the show well you can say whatever dumb
[ __ ] you want to say right we will we
will not do anything you can you can say
whatever you want and then
he goes
because i was like oh he rather he he
said that we should stop talking about
something yeah yeah and i was like oh
well that goes against the first member
right you're you're trying to suppress
our oh no he said we should stop cussing
we should right yeah yeah yeah
and yeah
and then of course and then of course
his next response was okay you [ __ ]
got me
yeah yeah well
we sure did bounced [ __ ] don't do not
yeah
you can say whatever the hell you want
to say about me was there an elon update
well
he won't he won't own twitter where's
the eye guy the i guy hadn't been back
since we
since we uh yeah since we kind of broke
we liked the eye guy here yeah we didn't
yeah we didn't ban him
maybe he banned himself i don't know i
don't know
if anyone out there has got the eye guy
on their uh
on their radar tell them to come back so
i can tell them
twitter
all i could say is uh
i've had i have elon posts on twitter
since then
and he has not
commented on anything i i i posted
a lot of the elon tweets that we had
that every day just goading waiting for
him to come in you know i'm trying i'm
trying the associated press has the elon
news here uh breaking elon musk says his
deal to buy twitter can't move forward
he's refusing to move forward unless
unless gabe the company shows public
proof
that less than five percent of accounts
are platformer fakers how the [ __ ] how
in the [ __ ]
doesn't he know this i'm sure gabe can
you can you run a check on his account
to see how many [ __ ] yeah
i'll do
how many bots are following his dumbass
like come on man how could you not know
that the [ __ ] pla that's the whole
point and that one of the things that he
said the reason why he was buying is
because he's gonna get rid of the bots
yeah like that was one of the things
he's like yeah we're gonna have freedom
of speech and no more bots [ __ ] the bots
we're gonna get rid of him yeah now he's
like blaming him he's claiming the bot
check broke the nda
is violating the contract so he should
not have to pay
the 44 billion or the 1 billion again we
set it from we said it from the
beginning he's going to find a way out
whether it was on because there was the
moment when he was having interactions
where he's bashing twitter execs and i
said he's purposely trying to get out of
this deal
as a means to avoid the 44 billion
whether he has to pay the billion
obviously one billion versus 44 is a
huge difference but if he can try to get
out of the one billion but i think
that's what he's trying to do here don't
you oh no no
he's trying to say you're breaking your
agreement so i don't have to he's he's
trying to get them to pay a billion
dollars and that's what he's going to
try to do is go on this this tirade and
get his [ __ ] bot army his bot army
yeah completely [ __ ] but i i want to
point something out that's really
important this five percent figure that
he's like talking about
is only based on a hundred accounts of a
sample size so i want to repeat this the
five percent figure that uh elon musk is
bitching about right now and trying to
get out of his deal with twitter is
based on a hundred account sample size
from twitter you mean he's 100 little
[ __ ]
yeah you mean yo wait a second wait
you're telling me
elon musk is a whiny little [ __ ]
[ __ ]
come on
i don't buy it for a second
that [ __ ] flake he was gonna flake on
this deal from the very beginning when
someone when someone suggested that he
was even going to get a board seat when
they when he had to reveal how much
stock he had bought and they were like
oh he's going to get a board seat and
he's going to bring back trump and all
this [ __ ] i was like this is all a
bunch of [ __ ] and i said it from the
very beginning he is a [ __ ] flake
he's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] he's he's
the king of the insults right here's
what i think is happening
i think ever since this manga king
started to circulate around this ultra
maga manga king i think elon musk
has really really gotten jealous and
he's like you know what i think what i
want to do is i want to be the manga
king i want to be king dangling i want
to be ultra modern
yeah maybe so did you find out how many
bots this guy's getting sorry i got
quickly uh sidetracked because i was
reading about this well there's another
there's another fact that's out there
about bots and elon musk apparently when
um and tesla stock several years ago was
plummeting um he actually uh implemented
uh several hundred of bot accounts that
were circulating thousands and thousands
and thousands of tweets um through
through a whole period of time i think
it's like an eighteen month period of
time i i can't remember right i didn't
read the entire thing but yeah
he's got bots that attack other people
for attacking him and then right
pro
elon
what
you know what we should do we should get
us we should get us some pro [ __ ]
bots that's what we should do that's
what i'm saying what do you guys think
do you think guys think we should invest
in some pro and like we should not make
it like we should not hide it gabe like
we should like be out right like these
are our bots this is our bot we own them
we own them and they will say what the
[ __ ] they want
it should be it should say [ __ ] them and
then it should be a little kiss remember
that one time you you tried to you wrote
a message and i was like you got to send
a little kiss emoji oh yeah
charlie kirk yeah charlie yeah yeah and
then the notification didn't show up to
be like sure you want to say this and it
was just say [ __ ] them
with the kiss yeah with the kiss
yeah i think we should start our own bot
farm i'm i'm all in i'm all in
i am totally in for it all right hold on
so so um uh the the story is is that
elon musk uh is not only not gonna buy
twitter he was never
folks he was never gonna buy twitter
this guy is a [ __ ] flake he is he's a
[ __ ] flake let me show you
i i got proof i know this is redundant
but here you go
he doesn't own twitter yet and he's a
flake let me prove it this is proof that
he's a flake i know this seems trivial
here's a picture of elon musk with a
haircut look at this here i'll make it
bigger he flaked on his haircut this is
not a finished haircut he did not even
let the barber finish his haircut look
at this guy does this look like a guy
that finishes anything come on give me a
break he doesn't own twitter yet and i
have said from the very beginning he
won't own it you you were doubtful of me
in the beginning the first there were
two days in the beginning and i only
looked at and i said now that the now
that the actual paperwork has been
presented i was like i'm 50 50 this goes
out and then two days went by and i
considered the situation even more in
terms of how the board could vote on on
tesla against him where the money would
have to go which would be tesla you know
the the lack of secured funding which i
guy who was very adamant that he had it
and then it was like oh it's semantics
he he owns it and then but he doesn't
own it no
so uh it took two days to kind of go
through read the paperwork assess the
situation and then come in and say okay
i believe no doubt
it won't happen
it's not what it's never gonna happen uh
yeah here i'll show you more proof of
that i'm a prophet here and i'm an elon
prophet there you go this is from april
25th
it says remember last week elon musk was
going to buy twitter and then the week
before that next monday is going to be a
party and here we are
tuesday may 17th and i'm still saying
this [ __ ] is not gonna buy
twitter it's all [ __ ] it's all
trolling [ __ ] that [ __ ] i've said it
from the beginning he's not gonna buy
never was gonna own he is a little whiny
[ __ ] and he got himself in a situation
where he tweeted out something really
[ __ ] dumb his entire [ __ ] bot army
and his stands took it seriously
and he put himself in a situation where
he had to keep pretending and it may
cost him a billion dollars but here's
the thing here's how sick this [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] is willing to spend a
billion dollars
on a stupid [ __ ] tweet thread that he
had i mean you think about that dude
dude a billion dollars to own the libs
baby oh well hey man i'm all for that
really honestly i think i think we
should tax the [ __ ] out of him for
owning the libs but whatever so here's
another tweet of mine this is the 27th
so this is two days later everyone's
still doubting me at this point
if i'm right about elon musk flaking on
the twitter deal does that mean i get
the 45 billion because you know what i
do the 45 billion i mean i keep a little
bit of it but if i got the 45 billion
i'd probably i'd buy macbooks for all
the red states that would be good like
real
[ __ ] hard at crt in it right i would
buy macbooks with the [ __ ] hard-ass
crt in it not that light ass crt no i
mean
yeah i'm talking about the ones that
solve for the inequality that's right
woke ass [ __ ] math books [ __ ] i
would buy woke ass macbooks for all the
[ __ ] red states and i'd dump them on
ron desantis
oh i was gonna say you you buy them for
all the all the schools so they have
them and then you buy a second copy
right for the same exact amount and then
you dump it on his lawn right on all
right just just put like a stack a
castle
rick scott
uh
marco rubio all those [ __ ] they
all get a second edition
uh math book that is literally we and we
we use the 45 billion to reprint the
math books right their own version the
schools get the real stuff but ron
desantis marco rubio uh
rick scott and all those other guys they
get their own version that actually has
the teachings of crt in them the top is
like crt is coming for you and then
maybe maybe it's just like hundreds and
hundreds of pages of just crt crt crtc
rtcrt you're racist crtc rtcrt you know
just stuff like that i think the other
thing i do with the 45 billion
is i would make sure they're printed on
unflammable paper like you couldn't
learn them yeah so like they have a huge
bonfire to throw them on there and they
try to keep this fire going for days and
days and the books never burn i don't
know maybe it's just like maybe just
like metal right like you should like
stamp it into metal you know right right
right and and then just so they couldn't
burn them speaking of speaking of oh i
got it do you have our figures do you
have our figures yeah okay let's hear
the elon musk bot figures
so how many followers does he have he
has uh
93 million 93 million oh there's got to
be way more than oh my garage
bot number 93 million
uh 300 something
and 13.4
million are fake
[Laughter]
wait you're saying he wait wait wait
you're saying he's bitching at a hundred
of accounts there's five there was five
bots that they found five which means
yeah yeah
or they yeah yeah they five percent yeah
uh of the hundreds of five bots
his account
85
real 15
bots
15 fake and i bet it's not like they
accidentally like a majority of that
doesn't accidentally follow him because
there's fake accounts that follow
everyone oh you guys ever noticed like
like like a porn bot well volley you're
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] yeah
yeah but but i mean i get people i mean
i get real
people in porn that follow me and also
hey i i'm i'm good any porn stars out
there you're welcome i'll follow you
back hell i'll go look at your page if
you want yeah you know if i'm not you
know i'm not we're not going to josh
we'll like it we'll like a tweet you
know and won't be ashamed of it like ted
cruz yeah exactly we we do not we do not
porn shame here we're not this is not
josh holly land we definitely think sec
sex work is work so and we're we're pro
or can we say we're pro porn is that
allowed i don't know porn we're pro porn
i mean you can't you can't spell porn
without pro that's true that's true you
cannot spell
you cannot spell prone prawn
[ __ ]
oh man see now you got me my my mind
your mind get out of there hawthorne i
know
i know
the call thorn ask watch talk and now
you're on porn the game you're just but
anyways anyways the bots back
to the box the box 15
so he's got he's got 13 million bots 13.
how much would it cost for us to buy 13
million bucks to like to see if we could
level a campaign and see if we could get
13 million bots let's
see let's see that would be that would
be really [ __ ] weird if it goes from
you know a couple thousand to 13 million
overnight right yeah um
let's how much does it cost for 13
million bots how much did elon pay for
13 million bucks i wonder if these are
like good bots or they're just like
mediocre
you know
like does he does he does he like
you know when he's buying them he's like
ah those are okay bots you know he's
really upset about the five percent of
bots
let's say 13 million pounds i don't even
know if i could do it i oh i can't buy
more than 25 000 at a time that's
[ __ ] well how much is 25 000. let's
see how much 25 000. 25 000 uh fake
followers would cost us six hundred and
fifty nine seventy so
thirteen million mm-hmm probably doing
the math here guys guys it's crt math
right now oh my god
take 13 million and you divide it by 25
000.
someone call ron desantis
520 now you multiply the 520 by the six
what is it say 79 yeah how much is it
659
70
yeah
it would cost us uh 343 044 that's a
pretty damn good deal i mean he's he
he's complaining about buying twitter
yeah for 44 45 billion is what he wants
to try to pay which is way undervalued
now after he's [ __ ] tanked
30 is the mid 30s i think oh yeah [ __ ]
it's dropped like significantly yeah and
it's all because he's trying to buy
exactly like the [ __ ] this [ __ ] that
thing or [ __ ] if he's
like [ __ ] this twitter's like [ __ ] this
anyway so if anyone was following we
just did some crt math and we found that
we can buy the same amount of fake
twitter followers that elon musk has for
the small small price
of 343 000
so for 343 grand is what we got to raise
yeah to make sure
maybe like a gofundme we can have we can
have like a bot war an elon musk bot
like our bots and here's the thing i'm
buying these are these are american
american-made bots oh okay so okay these
are american prices if i go overseas
like if i hit up russia i'm sure i could
get a lot of much cheaper for more and
potentially more effective at you know
targeting the anti-musk pro [ __ ] fan
see we we know that his bots are
probably russian bots so would you would
you say that it's a good idea to have
russian bots fighting russian bots in
the bot war or would it be better to
have american all-american patriot bots
i think
i think we could look at this and say we
need a
we need a russia v russia war we need
them to attack each other we need the
infighting to continue within the party
of the gqp right it's a pro-putin party
infighting must continue right so that
once they demolish each other
then we are left with american bots
and we don't have to
you know the result of any casualties
it's great well let's let's continue to
uh discover
what is the possibilities with farming
bots to battle
in the bot war
against elon musk where he has 13 folks
he's got 13 million bots that follow him
and he's bitching he's gonna end the
twitter deal over five
five porn bot accounts because that's
that has to be what they are as porn
bots right that half yeah i would have
said it has to be i mean maybe one of
them's i mean holly probably has more
than five percent bots on his account or
rather how many how many uh
stock puppet accounts does holly have
right that are porn bodyguards like he
is maybe he's maybe he's like 250 000
of elon's porn box
he's got his own jerk off stock puppet
account that's right that's right yeah i
would imagine i would imagine he does i
don't know how you keep up with the
passwords but
well josh hawley is committed to it he
just has them written
josh hawley has the
has the passwords to the accounts of his
sock puppet porn accounts written into
the margins of the bible oh my god yeah
like so on the sides yeah that's how he
remembers he's like oh deuteronomy of
passage 14 verse six through seven uh oh
yeah the password is uh tally whacker
yeah tally whacker one thousand because
you know you sometimes you gotta have oh
yeah you gotta put in the you know
you're gonna put in a number and it's
like callie wagger with a capital t
one thousand right and three k's you
know tally whacker right kkk you gotta
have the kkk oh we got
we got something coming in here in game
live
super jet thank you nolan for the super
sticker
so
so the math the crt math of the 13
million uh trying to trying to get the
the bots to battle elon musk in a bot
war
it's very interesting that it would be
that amount but did you it's speaking of
education and math and crt and ron
desantis did you see the news
um
about the board of education
in florida did you see this did you see
this news here um so let me pull this up
on the screen here uh kyle griffin
has the news here republican ron
desantis which a fascist would be more
appropriate fascist ron desantis just
picked a new secretary of state his wife
though
who is on the state board of education
okay
supported the capital riot so she's an
insurrectionist and defended q anon
theories
that the world is run by satan
worshiping child molesters
so so here we have here we have ron
desantis picking uh q anon husband and
wife for school board of ed our board of
education in the state of florida and
also the new secretary of state right
yeah double dipping little nepotism no
big deal well the other it's queuing on
episode nepotism right
yeah and you know so all you floridians
out there
now you gotta wow here's the thing i
just thought that ron desantis's wife
was just
his wife and there was nothing more
because it doesn't seem very
republican to let the wives out of the
kitchen out of the house right it seemed
like it would be like stay home raise
the kids make me a sandwich right that's
what republicans
would would push for right especially
because you've got people like margie
taylor greene who says men are the ones
who are superior they're the superior
race they're the ones who should know
the superior gender right now sorry the
spirit gender well come on you know well
assumed because she's white you know
right she's
very white racist
um
but it's very interesting that you have
people like margie taylor green who are
pro you know pro men you know superior
gender they're the ones who should be
running things and ron desantis over
here who is a fascist very much like
marjor taylor green is allowing his wife
out of the house and she's part of the
board of education no no no no no no no
no corey bird's wife oh corey bird is
the new secretary of state
okay
yeah i thought you said i thought it
said the way that it reads go back up
picked his new secretary of state which
is uh
the way that okay without seeing the
link here it goes up and says republican
ronnie sanders just picked a new his
wife
he's on this state secretary of state
gabe okay okay okay so the guy
for a moment i thought it was his wife
but even more so
it's another
pro-fascist person
who allowed their wife to be out of the
house right right
and serve in government which is not
what republicans are going to want you
do not want to you do not want to have
women running things
goddamn what where does where does the
name chord come from
chord oh it is report i thought it was
corey but it's corny bird cord bird
cardboard cord bird hey what are you
guys here tonight we're having some cord
bird
it sounds like a dish i got a i got a
cord bird sandwich over here yeah man i
got a cord bird stuck in my ass well uh
you know
again it is it is what it is but here's
the thing here's the thing is that
doesn't this guy look this guy looks
like ron desantis before he tried to
impersonate donald trump you remember
the way ron desantis used to look mm-hmm
and then before he really started to
pack on the pounds he changed his
haircut right he started to put the
tanner on he started the the you know
the hand movements
he really he doesn't have the voice down
yet but he's kind of got the cadence
down of
the
the manga king mm-hmm um but here we
have uh cord bird
i'm gonna be the secretary of state and
his wife who is a q a honor yep is on
the board of education this sounds
familiar when you talk about genie
thomas and clarence thomas where we have
uh married q and honors
inside of our government and this is the
reason why it's important today
to go
[Music]
[ __ ] vote yep to go [ __ ] vote your
outrage has to be counted
today it has to be counted remember
democracy only works if you vote
well and you have to not just vote you
have to encourage your friends to vote
talk to him about voting talk to him
about what's on the ballot who's on the
ballot and what's not
are you have situations like this where
ron desantis is picking cue and honors
to be on the board of education and
secretary of state in a state like
florida yeah cramming
gail here super sticker from gail thank
you very much for the superstar
thank you uh kitkat in the chat brings
up a good point here what do we got what
do we got
uh
i just saw it it's gone boom here we go
remember court is in charge of
overseeing the elections right yes
serious states so that's a big one
that is another big one here so a cue an
honor a q an honor is not only in the
board of education that's why they're
banning [ __ ] math in florida right
but the person who counts the you know
does the actual math before the election
yeah yeah is a queuing on her who wants
to ban math probably yeah wow i don't
know how they're
they're doing their their
uh they're arithmetic right but it's
gonna be really hard if you aren't
educated on how to do simple addition
well i bet they're not using crt with
their arithmetic they're probably using
wrt
wrt which is the good kind of rt right
yeah
yeah you're gonna have an rt the best
the best one out there the best one out
there white replacement uh
theory uh here is kate she says
pennsylvania georgia north carolina
kentucky idaho oregon get out and vote
blue in the primaries today lives depend
on it and every vote counts do your part
yeah this is true uh take this to heart
again like i said earlier it is now time
right now is the time to make your
outrage count go [ __ ]
vote so thank you kate for the and when
she says lives
depend on it literally
right literally lives depend on this is
not one of those like uh metaphors or
like exaggerations or
evidence or whatever it is like it's
literally
lives are at stake right you look at the
situation in different states in terms
of uh healthcare access for women and
the reproductive rights you you know
voting rights you look at uh just any
other sort of programs that would help
um
certain individuals you know that that
constituents obviously would be voting
against to help them because it's a
it's a handout or whatever it is based
on the republican party these are
programs that help these are programs
that advance
and and grow
communities and help individuals
um and so we need people who are
pro-democracy
pro-rights you know especially health
care
um you know women's rights women's
rights which we're going to show a video
um
midas robin and she's got a video she
wants to show so i hope i can find that
and bring it up on the screen but i get
another video here speaking of making
sure that we elect
folks that can have some common sense
[ __ ]
um some common sense [ __ ]
when we're talking about policy we have
tucker carlson last night
on fox news
reading gabe he rushed to read
this manifesto of this manga king mass
shooter in buffalo and i believe he
rushed to read it because he was like oh
man what's this guy got in this
manifesto maybe we can use some of this
stuff on the show right oh man we could
really use some of this this rhetoric on
the show i'm sure
um of course he he found out very
quickly
that it that it was him in the manifesto
giving this deluded [ __ ] this manga king
mass shooter in buffalo nobody did i
just want to know
he had
from from saturday this happened
saturday right and he's reporting us on
monday he did not have anyone do any
sort of reading or fact checking to look
at this and say oh dude your reference
like a hundred times in this thing man
and he's saying that you're the [ __ ]
messiah and savior that gave him the the
idea to go and do this right well and
they cherry pick because yesterday we
heard some trolls saying in our chat
that that he was he was it was actually
authoritarian or was it the one we
announced
um so yesterday he was saying that that
the the maga king mass shooter in
buffalo um that guy was actually a
leftist authoritarian and there is a
clip out there of steve ben and i will
try to find it and this is where they
got it they got it from the trader tv
channels um and tucker carlson doesn't
go quite as far to call him a leftist
here but he definitely downplays the
idea that this guy was quoting him word
for word of the reason why he went and
shot black people because that's what
the [ __ ] guy was doing the manga king
mass shooter went he was he was given
inspiration by putin's puppet here and
all the [ __ ] maga maga king
worshipers out there to go shoot black
people i wonder i wonder how he could
have gotten those ideas from these
people let's listen to this [ __ ] box try
to [ __ ] figure out and try to work
through this manifesto to see if he can
use some of it on his goddamn show
but what he wrote does not add up to a
manifesto it is not a blueprint for a
new extremist political movement much
less the potential inspiration for a
racist revolution
i mean he was really hoping tucker
carlson was really hoping here that this
guy would write a manifesto that would
really start a political revolution
something that tucker could get behind
right gabe think his teeth into that's
right really i mean really he wanted to
be able to publish this thing on his
show but it's kind of half-assed right
it's not a real political manifesto that
would stoke fear and start a race world
war god damn i mean we we need one of
those but this isn't just it yet gabe
this manga king mass shooter that tucker
inspired just didn't get the memo for
the manifesto and he kind of half-assed
it a bit i think that's what tucker's
saying here yeah
let's let's finish
anyone who claims that it is is lying or
hasn't read it
ins cause he's read it he rushed to read
it i mean he was like whoa there's 180
page manifesto that has my name in it a
hundred times [ __ ] the last time he read
something that quick
might have been mind conf i don't know
maybe you'll read trump's new book
oh the gathering one yeah the coloring
book right his memoir yeah his memoir
the coloring book yeah it what what did
you you you tweeted about it yesterday
yeah i said uh trump told a bunch of
rally goers that he's writing a new book
called the crime of the century and i
said and honestly i think that's a great
title for memoir
when you try to overthrow a government
and try to be the fascist dictator with
putin's puppet here at your side uh
let's finish here what the bonehead has
to say instead gendron's letter is a
rambling pastiche of slogans and
internet memes some of which flatly
contradict one another the document is
not recognizably left-wing or right-wing
it's not really political at all he's so
full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
what a bunch of [ __ ] it's it's it's it's
a bunch of contradictions political
contradictions but it's not politic he
always says [ __ ] two things at once
right you [ __ ] fence straddle and
fascist
hitler would be completely disappointed
in this ninja poop nazi like dude stick
your stake in the fascist sand and stay
there i just i also want to point out
that far right-wing groups are behind
most of the u.s terrorist attacks that
happen here in this country right okay
white supremacists have carried out a
majority of the terrorist plots and
attacks right in 2021 and also in 2022
okay and this is not based on some
accusation this is based on actual
studies that have been done so you've
got tucker carlson who's trying to he's
like oh [ __ ] oh it's neither left wing
or right wing uh i don't want to
associate it with right wing you know
even though it is this kid is the one
who's like oh in the last two years i've
been totally indoctrinated by people
like dr carlson and white should replace
everyone you know and it's like dude i'm
sorry but at the end of the day it's far
right-wing nut jobs that are pushing
these people to go commit these crimes
because they believe that their voice is
being suppressed and they're the
minority and they don't have the rights
anymore but you you remember last week
when tucker carlson was just [ __ ]
offended i mean just [ __ ] and the
right was offended
that the the mayor of chicago
said
now is the time to call the arms to to
make sure that women have liberty in
this country and they're like oh my god
you're stoking violence oh that's why
all these leftists are burning down
these cities whatever the [ __ ] they say
yeah yeah and here's tucker carlson like
no just because he said that i i told
him he should go shoot black people i
don't believe that right
he's like it's full of it's full of
memes and they all contradict each other
it's not that right now they're left i
can't i can't be associated and i cannot
take any responsibility right i
definitely want credit though let's
listen to the credit that he wants
the document is crazy it's the product
of a diseased and organized mind at one
point gender suggests that fox news is
part of some global conspiracy against
him
they are
they they certainly are and tell me
where where he says a lie here
like i don't know the guy works for
[ __ ] murdock
murdoch and fox news
is is a is a deep-rooted problem in this
country all right
oh my god this guy gives the gives the
[ __ ] game away when he's like they
accused us of deluding him yeah you did
you dumb [ __ ] jesus christ he
writes like the mental patient he is
disjointed irrational paranoid
now that's true not that it makes the
atrocities he committed easier to bear
if your daughter was murdered on
saturday in buffalo you wouldn't care
why the killer did it or who he voted
for
but the truth about peyton gendron does
tell okay i want to stop there because i
think that's a bunch of [ __ ] too to
believe that the people in the community
that where this grocery store happened
aren't worried about [ __ ] white
supremacists that are [ __ ] inspired
by a ninka poop nazi like tucker carlson
to drive 200 miles to come kill members
of their community you are a
[ __ ] bonehead this is
ridiculous that no one in that community
is worried about other [ __ ]
white guys who were ex inspired inspired
by the ninja poop nazi that tucker
carlson is to come and kill more members
of their community you are a [ __ ]
idiot tucker carlson i mean anyone who
believes is garbage and not only that
but you have to remember that like when
he just said right now he's like oh no
one's gonna care who they voted for [ __ ]
yes you're going to care who they voted
for if i know that these people who come
in and
and do these attacks on other people
voted for trump because trump said we
got to make america great again and
really it's a dog whistle to say white
people should rule the land again and
non-white people should not have rights
anymore if that's the person in your
party who is actively telling people at
rallies go kill go go get that son of a
[ __ ] go knock i'll pay for the i'll pay
for the uh for the legal bills to cover
when you get arrested you know go get
that person over there go beat him up go
do this right and when you see spikes in
2020 from these in in the areas where
rallies were were held and you find that
they're associated with trump trump is
very pro-violence why do you think we're
in the problem that we have right now
pro-white pro-violence
pro-getting rid of any rights of people
who are non-white it's like how do you
think we got the situation because
people like tucker carlson are there
just regurgitating and pushing that
narrative of white replacement theory
right and so now
tucker carlson tries to play victims say
i don't know hey guys let's not
associate it with this right or laugh
this guy was sick in the head it was
mental illness it wasn't the gun and it
wasn't the [ __ ] that i told him to do or
say on the news that he rather said it
wasn't
that he said it was the [ __ ] that i told
him to do in the show i told him
don't don't believe what he says this
guy's crazy okay this guy's out of his
mind you can't believe any word that he
says it's like he's he's doing a pebble
of frog memes over here you know and
don't don't don't don't believe anything
he says especially when he mentions my
name tucker carlson and especially when
he quotes me verbatim for the different
programs that i had on the news don't
don't believe him guys okay okay just
believe me in my entertainment show
his entertainment show tell you a lot
about the ruthlessness and dishonesty of
our political leadership
within minutes of saturday's shooting
before all of the bodies of those ten
murdered americans had even been
identified by their loved ones
professional democrats had begun a
coordinated i love that professional
democrat what the [ __ ] does that mean
professional democrats i don't know do
you get paid
do you get paid to be a democrat i
didn't is it like uh this is the crisis
actor i don't know what he's trying to
do well here's what i think you know
they're always projecting so there's
actually i think there's actually people
out there that are getting paid to be
republican
oh 100 yeah paid democrats like what the
[ __ ] are you professional democrat what
are you talking about what are you are
you talking about people who are elected
what the [ __ ] because every accusation
is a confession god damn i remember that
you goddamn right it is
the campaign to blame those murders on
their political opponents they did it
they said immediately patron gendron was
the heir to donald trump they told us
trumpism committed mass murder in
buffalo i mean it did so yeah yeah right
it's the your ass
spewing [ __ ] white replacement theory
of maga ism trumpism fascism in a
[ __ ] maga hat right
inspired the manga king mass shooter to
go kill black people what the [ __ ] don't
you understand about it it's not
difficult to understand especially when
you've got people like tucker carlson
who are making [ __ ] documentaries
about kyle rittenhouse right and pushing
how kyle was innocent and he's actually
pro blm and he's not a racist
when you have someone like this who is
defending a white person who went out
with an ar-15 illegally by the way to go
kill black people
in wisconsin and then got caught for it
right and then was on trial
you've got this guy who is trying to
advocate that this kid is innocent and
he's actually just a nice 17 18 year old
boy and there's nothing to worry about
and actually it was the other people who
caused it and he was just defending
himself well it would never been a
problem the kid didn't go across state
lines with or rather he went across
state lines and then acquired an illegal
ar-15 the same type of rhetoric that
he's using to defend this white kid cow
ring house is the same type of stuff
that let that kid feel that he was
justified to go to this grocery store
and kill 10 people yeah because cut
tucker carlson would think he's cool
tucker carlson would think he's the next
ridden house it's the ridden house rule
as it is in this country where tucker
carlson would sycophant him and but
unbeknownst unbeknownst to the manga
king mask shooter is that kyle
rittenhouse didn't say well tucker
carlson's the reason why i went to go
shoot black people um and this this guy
is going to be tossed aside when you say
the quiet part out loud let's listen to
the rest of the [ __ ] quiet part out
loud here
and for that reason it followed
logically we must suspend the first
amendment
so tucker carlson's saying that the
first amendment is suspended because
this guy
had his second amendment right to go
kill black people because that's the
truth of the matter because we found out
just in the last last several days over
as this story has developed
that the manga king mass shooter in
buffalo
was threatening to shoot up a school
and he was investigated court ordered to
have a mental evaluation during that
time a mental evaluation quarter minnow
evaluation the [ __ ] was able to
buy three weapons legally in this
country and again i say again and again
and again and again and again
and again the good guy bad guy [ __ ] does
not hold up and this is [ __ ] this is
the reason why they don't give a [ __ ]
about you they don't give a [ __ ] about
this guy going and killing black people
because the the main the main thing of
this is to make sure that this guy can
buy more guns this guy has to be able to
buy more guns it's important
and i do i do want to expand on
something that i said yesterday on the
whole good guy bad guy with the gun
situation
one thing i said yesterday was it was a
bold assumption
to to rely on someone else
and whether super uh uh supermarket uh
security guard or whether it's you're
hoping somebody's gonna be
uh legally caring right you're hoping
that somebody will take action
to stop this
this bad person with a gun right this
bad guy with the gun
that is
not only a bold assumption
but i think it's [ __ ] insane
that we live in a society
where we now have to assume that
somebody else
is going to save the day
that somebody else whether it's a
minimum wage security guard who doesn't
have much training is now going to try
to overtake some person with an ar-15 or
someone who has a lot of training a
former police officer exactly or you're
hoping that some guy has a gun in his
ankle or on his waist or whatever is now
going to in that moment which is a
[ __ ]
intense traumatic stressful moment to
make a split-second decision to say i'm
now going to point this weapon and shoot
this person you know who is also
decked out in gear and uh has a flak
jacket and is protected
to assume that somebody would risk their
own life
to protect others
is wild
in the fact that we live in a society
where we have to just say
don't worry about it a good guy with a
gun is going to save the day
and and
a good guy is going to
a good guy with the gun is going to kill
the other good guy with a gun because
this guy who went to buffalo drove 200
miles to kill
black people this white supremacist who
was inspired by the good guy that he
sees it as tucker carlson and the good
reasoning why he had and he had the
right to go kill people he didn't like
and he was going to start a race war and
it was gonna be all hunky-dory and it
was gonna be great and the manga king
was gonna be the king of the castle king
of the castle king of the castle this is
all [ __ ] that guy thought he was the
good guy with the gun the [ __ ] manga
king mass shooter in buffalo thought he
was the good guy with the gun the bad
guys were the ones in the store that
tucker carlson told him they were the
bad guys that's the [ __ ] truth
speaking of people who try to make
themselves victims in all this [ __ ]
manga king mass shooter we have jd
mandel excuse me jd vance katy vance is
jd mandel's [ __ ]
worst enemy oh my god this guy this
[ __ ] guy playing victim listen to
this game listen to this guy playing
victim of how
the manga king mass shooter going to
buffalo and killing black people he's
the real victim here gabe he's the
victim he's the one that gets all the
blow back it's ridiculous i mean it's
almost like he was killed 10 times over
in that grocery store [ __ ] let's
listen
uh the three people i've seen blamed are
not the shooter the guy who actually
cared about this violence but donald
trump tucker carlson and me i've heard
me criticize because i'm an advocate
allegedly of some conspiracy theory that
motivated this guy look it's insane you
don't use tragedies to advance your
political agenda
um okay you may want to look at the
republican party then oh my god this
[ __ ] [ __ ] box i can't take this
anymore [ __ ] jd vance [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him all day long he's upset he's
upset that he has a white man
is getting blamed he's upset that donald
trump is getting blamed sorry donald
trump is the one that created a
pro-violent society right like look the
boogeyman was in the closet and donald
trump let it out
and now it's totally fine and that
motherfucker's not going back in the
closet okay you got tucker carlson who
is pushing white uh wrt white
replacement theory and advocating
for the white man who is being
so suppressed and so oppressed in his
voice and his rights and this and that
and he has to say you know what today i
take a stand as an alpha ball tanning
male
i'm gonna take my ar-15 and i'm gonna
show everyone that i deserve the respect
that i should get
and that
is where we are today and jd [ __ ]
vance over here
feels butt hurt because his name is
thrown in i don't know who here's the
thing i don't know who actually is
throwing his name around or if they're
actually blaming him but i also wouldn't
be surprised if jd vantage threw his own
name in there right right and
just said like many people are talking
about many people are blaming me people
are saying the top three people are
trump tucker carlson and me
yeah i highly [ __ ] doubt his name was
ever [ __ ] spoken in regards to the
shooting trump and tucker carlson 100
don't doubt it jd vance homie you just
went through a primary okay no one even
knows who you [ __ ] are not even trump
he called you jd mandel shut the [ __ ] up
and sit the [ __ ] out oh my god the guy
can't take his cheeto dust knee beds off
he just can't take his keto dusty beds
off you know you mentioned you mentioned
ball tanning um after this break we're
going to go to a quick break but when we
come back
i want to show you gabe someone who i
definitely think i don't have proof but
i i mean other than what he's posting on
twitter but i definitely think this one
tans his balls like constantly all the
time he might have on he might be
tanning them right now as we speak so
don't don't go anywhere we're going to
talk about ball tanning when we come
back right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome uncle welcome back to the show
as i promised before the break
i am going to show you proof
[Music]
of a tucker carlson type ball tanner
he's one of these religious types
gabey's he really
he he's almost like the pied piper of
the end cells if there is such a thing
oh yeah i know who you're going to bring
up you know he claims to be a doctor
he's not even he's he really likes to
attract american incels but he's he's
actually canadian um and a lot of people
you know in the chat this um
he's a clinical psychologist if i
remember correctly is that what he calls
himself just like just like rand paul is
a doctor right right right right right
well he needs to have his [ __ ] head
checked by someone because he tweeted
this uh let me pull down the uh the
okay i'm gonna pull up a clip
uh talking about something similar okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna comment on this
while you're doing that
dr jordan b peterson and apparently he's
left twitter because of this because he
was just too bullied i guess or some
[ __ ] i don't know he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
is what he is and it's not surprising
because he said sorry not beautiful
about this uh the newest
the sports illustrated swimsuit edition
uh
human new is the is the model on the
cover she's [ __ ] smoking hot she's
[ __ ] beautiful absolutely [ __ ]
gorgeous if anyone can't see it here she
is [ __ ] beautiful
and he says uh that's gonna call it out
i mean the guy is [ __ ] jealous right
well
he's not being oh i mean no one's listen
no one's gonna look at him and say yeah
you know what i want to put him on the
cover of sports illustrated
jordan peterson is a [ __ ] cuck
[Laughter]
he is definitely a cook and she is she's
[ __ ] gorgeous that's why they put her
on the cover yeah of sports illustrated
what in the [ __ ] how
anyways as if they made a mistake here
he said sorry not beautiful and no
amount of authoritarian tolerance is
gonna change what the [ __ ] does eddie i
don't even know what that means does he
mean that people are forcing people to
say that this is beauty what are you
talking about you fool
how can you not objectively say that she
is absolutely drop dead gorgeous i don't
care like who you who what your type is
or if you if you are sexually attracted
to women or not jordan i mean you know
it's questionable but she is absolutely
gorgeous
absolutely gorgeous
and
i said i said and i think this is where
i was going with it was the ball
painting 100
100 hours says jordan peterson tames his
balls now i haven't been wrong about a
lot gabe i have not been wrong wrong
about a lot
um i've been correct a lot lately so
maybe i'm right on this i don't know if
someone wants to take me up on it but um
but i bet i don't i don't know if anyone
now they would want to
like look like i you know i respect you
for the the
the prediction and claim that you have
here but i don't know if anyone in our
in our group is willing to get that
close and personal to know if jordan
peterson is tanning his butt oh so it's
so it's kind of it's kind of like about
the proof thing more than anything is
that what you're saying yeah yeah i just
don't i don't think people want to put
themselves through that you know i don't
think that's uh right you might have to
you know you might have to you might win
100 but then you have to pay someone a
hundred dollars just to go and find the
truth just to go exactly
just to look it up speaking of ball
tanners i almost guarantee this
[ __ ] dances balls too oh i i
would probably put a thousand dollars on
this [ __ ] tan in his bowls have
you seen the the pictures of the dudes
like laying out naked with their holding
their feet up in the air like tanning
their tanning their ass squatch like
they're oh like they're trying they're
trying to like suddenly it's their
[ __ ] right right well they're trying
to suntan their their nuts and their
butts
the nuts and butts at the same time nuts
and butts i i would almost bet that
there is a time that uh joe rogan has
stripped down and tanned his nuts and
butts at the same time almost guarantee
it no no doubt no doubt about it what's
this flip you got for me here with the
ball here this is a this is a clip
between joe rogan and uh jordan peterson
and
they're talking about you know rogan
talk well i mean i'll let the clip speak
for itself but basically they're talking
about um
uh uh pigmentation uh and also oh it's
like skin color yeah exactly so so are
they talking about tanning here or is it
just like racist type [ __ ] no it's just
like racist oh okay
tan it's like oh dark tan black white
like that whole spectrum of like what
shade you are
is discussed here and jordan peterson's
response is [ __ ] top
oh i bet it's racist as [ __ ] janie says
tanning their taints they are we're
going to watch two taint tanners talking
about other people's
pigmentation apparently i think i've
seen this clip before but you know
jordan peterson is a regular on joe
rogan's podcast because his audience is
jordan peterson's audience like it is
the cockiest of the cucks is joe rogan's
ability to have someone on as a guest
right and then immediately the next days
be like yep so this is what i believe
and i had this person on who was an
expert right and now i believe anyone
can say they're an expert and joe rogan
is the ultimate prime example
of the dunning-kruger effect right right
the facebook ivermectin group believing
it full stop just because you just read
it right let's listen to the clip
depending on who you ask either you're a
voice of reason and rationality and
and uh you know
personal responsibility
oh [ __ ] this guy's gonna talk about
reasonability and rationale and oh my
god oh [ __ ] this guy or
you're a voice of intolerance and
bigotry and anger and hateful
sexual oppression what did michael
prejudice dyson call you and me mean
every white mean yeah and and a mean
angry white man hilarious uh so they're
talking to about the eric dyson there um
he's a professor i believe
um he's he's a he's a black guy
obviously um that's why they're upset
that a black dude would call them how
dare you
how dare you call me racist when i say
racist things you son of a [ __ ] let's
listen
and by the way i want to point out um
it really is not surprising that this
the guy who's saying that she isn't
beautiful you dumb look at this [ __ ]
yeah look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] keeper
type [ __ ] in a bow tie and it
ain't surprising that he's on the same
spectrum as tucker carlson these bow tie
wearing [ __ ] not this i'm not
discriminating against bow tie wearers
it just seems that there's a pattern
here let's listen
yeah yeah you're not mean at all yeah
that's what's dumb about that statement
it's you're not mean at all it's i am
white he's racist you're just not mean
what the [ __ ]
like literally joe rogers like look that
that where he called you a mean bigoted
racist you're not mean yeah i mean of
course you're a racist bigot but you're
not mean about it right you're like
white racist and bigoted you're not or
like right white mean and bigoted you're
not you're not mean you know it's like
these three things only one can be true
right or rather one can be false it's
like two truths and a lie you know how
dare you call you mean that son of a
[ __ ] what an [ __ ] called you mean
you're not mean i mean you're a [ __ ]
bigot and we're about to find out how
big it you are
actually that's a lie too i'm kind of
tan and he was actually not black
because i'm i'm darker than you yeah
yeah that's ridiculous
okay so go go back go back and and hear
what he says
let's listen to it again actually that's
a lie too i'm kind of tan and he was
actually not black
he was sort of brown
so jordan peterson is trying to make the
argument and so is joe rogan
that black
is is like uh is like black like my hat
right
right exactly not an indication of like
oh that is your race your black white
whatever they're trying to say well he's
actually like light brown he's not
actually black and then they're gonna go
into a whole thing about how like like
what is
what is black why do they call them
black you know like it's
wait wait you're telling me you're
telling me they're not only going to be
racist they're going to be mean too
about it right babe you're not mean
they're not then you've got jordan
peterson over here who is probably
whiter than the goddamn t-shirt he's
wearing in his wannabe 80s tux right now
and he's going to try and say that some
black man is not actually black and he's
not actually white
homie
i could probably see through you you're
a [ __ ] ghost you're that white [ __ ]
this is ridiculous that this guy says he
it you know the most i mean he's going
to say some racist bigoted [ __ ] here but
the most ridiculous thing i think he's
said so far is that he's tan
what yeah he's like i'm not actually
white he's like actually that's a lie
too i'm not actually white i'm tan and
then
yeah i'm darker than you what's up with
this right like what what you're seeing
is not real what you're seeing is not
maybe maybe this is just more proof that
i'm right that he tans his balls because
maybe he's talking about his balls are
tan because we all know that these cucks
only
tan their balls right right be manly so
maybe that's it maybe that's it i don't
know
because i'm i'm darker than you yeah
yeah that's ridiculous yeah but neither
of us are white well i'm italian and he
was brown not black well isn't that
weird yeah it's really weird the black
and white thing is so strange because
the shades are shannon brown there's
such a spectrum of shades of people
unless you're talking to someone who is
like 100 percent african from the
darkest place where they're not wearing
any clothes all day and they've
developed all that melanin to protect
them what what the [ __ ] is he talking
about
what what does he talk like only people
from uh the darkest place where they
don't wear clothes is the per what the
[ __ ] is he talking about yeah he's like
only a real black person is someone in
africa who was totally exposed to the
sun everyone else yeah they're brown
yeah they're not black
and you and i we're not white we're
brown
cynthia points out a good point here oh
my god is this parody no they're they're
talking like seriously yeah this is them
actually having a conversation trying to
make themselves seem relevant by saying
how they're actually not the white guys
right they're not actually racist and
they're embarrassed they're not white
they're not white
and by the way how dare anyone
anyone insinuate that they're mean that
is ridiculous that is that if they're
going to be offended by anything
it's that you said they were mean and
that's not fair
jordan peterson let's let's finish the
[ __ ]
bigoted launch here because we know the
dismount is bigoted as [ __ ] themselves
from the sun
you know it's even the term black is
weird
and when you use it for people that are
literally my color
it becomes very strange yeah yeah you
know
this is true it's so you were asking me
when you use it for people that are my
color
again again is calling
a white person like joe rogan black
well what he's saying what he's saying
is if there's light-skinned black people
they're not black
right they're not black if you're light
skinned you're not black you're not
black it's this you know
oh my god
it just it never stops with these
[ __ ] so that's jordan peterson
yeah yeah and it is no wonder so
according to jordan peterson he's not
actually white
and he's not mentally not mean he's
definitely not mean he's definitely he'd
never address the racist part the
bigoted part i mean why would he why
why would he you don't have to address
it when you just double down on it right
right absolutely absolutely well and
jordan peterson not only is he is he a
[ __ ] bonehead and he's an incel and
he's a racist bigot but it's not
surprising he's super religious like he
uses religion and he said he he does
these really weird diatribes where he
says all these really big words to
impress uh incel white dudes but he says
nothing he seems like absolutely nothing
that sounds a lot like uh
ben shapiro yeah you know it it is funny
how charlie kirk ben shapiro jordan
peterson and some of these others are
like the pied pipers of alpha cucks it
really an intel alpha cuts it really is
funny how
all that that venn diagram just seems to
be a [ __ ] circle weird just a [ __ ]
circle speaking of weirdos and speaking
of weird christian people who use
religion
you gotta have you seen this [ __ ]
clip gabe you know greg lock is holy oh
yeah he's uh he's been banned from
twitter a couple times and then recently
came back and then i think within less
than 12 hours he was
off the platform again what do you mean
like he opened a new account kind of
like mike lindell did
uh i forget if he opened a new account
but let me see uh well i'm sure if i'm
looking for him he's i'm gonna he's
opening up elon musk
sock puppet russian bot accounts or
something
um i am trying to recall exactly what he
had done but i remember that he opened
up an account again and he was like i'm
back and then twitter was like nope
you're not
[Laughter]
well let me tell you before we play this
um elon musk won't buy twitter but in
the fantasy land of the elon stands
where uh elon would own twitter trump
wouldn't he would decide not to come
back to twitter but this guy definitely
would be on [ __ ] twitter and he would
be saying some vile [ __ ] [ __ ] because
you're about to listen to this guy
this guy i thought like mike flynn and
mike lindell and sydney powell and trump
are [ __ ] we wacko dos and weirdos
this [ __ ] this great lock
character takes the goddamn cake and man
does he use blasphemy on religion
uh to to actually preach antichrist type
[ __ ] like i'm not i'm not a religion i'm
an atheist yeah yeah i grew up i grew up
catholic
and that's probably why maybe i'm an
atheist i don't know exactly you know
there's a lot of reasons crazy it's
crazy if you kind of just like question
the church and be like yo this is all
kind of sucks doing this and you're like
shut up right kneel down in the pew and
pray right be catholic [ __ ] right like
that's basically um what happens but
this here
is just i mean it's kind of hard to
watch all war in the audience but man if
you're looking for some crazy because i
had a lot of people when i posted this
people like is this real is this guy
[ __ ] serious or this is this like a
movie what is this
but greg locke he seems to be dead
serious and really honestly gabe i bet
this guy has got [ __ ] bodies buried
in his crawl space
100 percent oh [ __ ]
this guy has got something going on
there's no way you're saying [ __ ] like
this and you ain't got something going
on somewhere oh yeah
he got something going on let's listen
to pastor [ __ ] here greg locke
i'm to the place right now if you vote
democrat i don't even want you around
this church you can get out i wouldn't i
i wouldn't even be near near a church
like this and frankly i mean i already
have a problem with this but okay
like we're two seconds into this [ __ ]
thing yeah and we're on he's a he's a
pastor he's a priest right he's he's a
man of god he's a man of christ right
right right a man of christ okay god
okay you know he's a pastor sorry
correctly he's a pastor
uh in the house of house of god he's
there to spread the word of god and i
actually think it's a tent of god
because this guy goes around it is
actually a circus
it's actually a circus he does set up
circumstance and he be he performs these
bigoted he's like weird diatribe right
up and spread the tent out and he's got
his little guitars back there for the
christian band to spread their hip
hypocrisy and their songs but you've got
a guy like this within the first two
seconds we watched he says if you're
democrat i don't even want you here
right he's the opposite teachings of
christ
and we're atheists and we know that
let's
let's continue with the insanity
you get out you demon
you can get out you baby butchering
election thief
you cannot be a christian and vote
democrat in this nation i don't care
i mean i get different it's almost funny
i mean it is kind of funny it is insane
especially when he was like oh man you
baby you baby uh election stealing
democrats like dude are you have you not
looked at the republican party
all of these people week after week
there is a new story about some
republican candidate or representative
or
you know former politician who gets
caught with child porn sex trafficking
uh uh
you know being a pedophile you know
going to prison for this like all of
these things not only that i mean
there's a ton of other vile things they
do also just like stealing and cheating
and this and that
this is the republican party it's almost
like again you know he's in a house at
this circus he's in a house of mirrors
right now he's looking at himself he's
like you you you you you you you and
he's just looking at himself man i i
would imagine that this gay
um definitely definitely has paid for
abortions one hundred percent as paper
abortion yeah yeah yeah without a doubt
without a doubt because he's gone
democrats butchers he's definitely
participated in some sort of election
fraud at some point and i i still would
say and i don't have any proof of this
but i would say that this guy's got
something he's hiding like you said
either either porn on his hunter buying
laptop his copy because they all got a
copy everyone's got a cut everyone got a
copy when they went to their you know
weekly meeting right white replacement
theory right you know so i would bet on
his thumb drive that has hunter binds
left copy 100 binds laptop he's probably
got some other [ __ ] on there and he's
probably got bodies buried somewhere
somewhere underneath the tent oh my god
damn man that makes you you get pissed
off as you want to you cannot be a
christian and vote democrat in this
nation they are god denying demons that
butcher babies and hate this nation
you got to hand it to him he's got a lot
of enthusiasm though yeah i mean really
this is he was able to spit a lot of
lies in that short amount of time [ __ ]
this guy is committed to this [ __ ] i
mean he is really fully on committed to
being not christ-like it is
it is astounding of how much talent he
has to be
not christian it is i think i think the
funniest thing there was how uh
democrats were the america hating group
when it's the republicans who are the
pro-putin group right which is weird
because you go back to reagan when it's
like tear down that wall it's like man
how how quickly we have shifted to the
complete opposite of the spectrum where
the republican party is now pro-putin
and pro-genocide
anti-life
that's what they are well right well i
mean they love watching putin commit war
crimes and killing innocent women and
children you know butchering children i
mean again it's all the projection i bet
if you asked greg locke about putin oh
he'd have all kinds of wonderful things
to say about
he's a wonderful leader he's a wonderful
man he really likes trump and he's a
good christian probably
was it locker who was the pastor that
said that we should pray for putin
look at that [ __ ] up why we're playing
the rest of this crazy [ __ ] diatribe
here
they hate this nation
get mad all you want to
i don't care if you stand i don't care
if you throw tomatoes please god i'm
about to throw a microphone up in his
house
so trump's scared of tomatoes but
griglock not scared no i'm scared not
scared
you cannot be a democrat and a christian
you cannot somebody say amen he really
he really keeps focusing on that
greg locke seems like he's possessed
like
if there ever was the devil you know
right and he came back and he's like i'm
gonna take over a body and the body i
chose is greg locke and this is it i'm
going to push this which is funny
because you just promote he's like i
thought democrats were the ones who were
you know
satanic and they're the ones who are
eating babies and butchering them and
doing this and doing that and he's on
stage saying how don't do it i'm like
doesn't really add up but he seems like
he's like
possessed by a demon like somebody needs
to do an exorcism on greg locke and get
whatever [ __ ] [ __ ] show is brewing
inside him out and that's he's doing
these people a very
very bad like just disservice he either
needs an exorcism or a straight jacket
one of the other i mean i looked up who
it was it was uh it was franklin graham
was the person
another preacher
who said we should pray for putin oh
well you know pray for putin to murder
innocent women and children that's what
we should be praying for you know baby
butchers
okay
the rest of you get out
get out
get out in the name of jesus
get out in the name of jesus now that
is some blasphemy he's doing some high
knees there get out in the name of jesus
is that the demon like trying to get out
i think that was that was the that was
the deal he's trying to keep it i don't
know maybe or here's another theory greg
locke actually took a demon
against their own will it's probably
just put him inside and then he's like i
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
this demon is freaked the [ __ ] out by
greg lock he's like what kind of host
body is this [ __ ] earth and vessel
get the [ __ ] out of here
oh my god this [ __ ] guy
i ain't playing your stupid games
bunch of
devils sick of it
they won't talk about the insurrection
[Music]
now this is where this is where it goes
from absolute batshit crazy like nuttier
than [ __ ] squirrel turds
to dangerous this is the language
that that the manga king mass shooter
this is the type of language that tucker
carlson is parroting jd vance is
parroting trump is parroting because
they're saying that people are saying
mike flynn is parroting these messages
at his [ __ ] nazi rallies
and nick fuentes is parroting this
language marjorie taylor greene matt
gatz jim jordan members of congress are
paroding this language listen to the
dangerous [ __ ] talk he says and how
he uses jesus
to justify his dangerous dog
let me tell you something
you ain't seen an insurrection yet is he
talking to me he's pointing to me he's
yeah he's like he's
he's pointing me who's he talking to i
don't know like i heard a guy in the
crowd say something and he's like you
ain't seen the insurrection yet boy yeah
let's let's see let's see what what
this they won't talk about the
insurrection
[Music]
tastes nude it's a reaction sandwich
dude he's like he's like josh hawley
when he opens up porn now he's like
is that the sound holly i think josh
hawley makes he he like gets out that
grunt like
moan he's like
that's what he does
i don't know i don't know but he really
he insurrection sandwich
let's listen
let me tell you something
yeah you ain't seen the insurrection yet
no we watched it we watched it you keep
on pushing our buttons you low down
sorry compromisers
you god hating communism you'll find out
what the insurrection is because we
ain't playing your garbage we ain't
playing your mess my bible says that the
church of the living god is an
institution that the gates of hell shall
not prevail against it and the bible
says that we'll take it by force that's
what the bible says
that's what the bible says
it's gonna get worse
so he's threatening who
and he's using the bible because his
bible says his bible says that he has to
you have to go uh create and commit
insurrections and kill the devil demon
democrats apparently it says it in the
bible people wonder how we get
home-grown terrorists white
home-grown terrorists you gotta look at
people like greg locke tucker carlson
donald trump
maybe that's who jd vance thought he was
talking about he was like there are
three people that always get thrown into
the mix it's donald trump tucker carlson
and he heard greg locke right but he
wanted to play
jd vance he's like they're talking about
me jd vance when they're really talking
about people like [ __ ] crazy like
greg locke who's possessed by a demon
that the demon doesn't even want to be
in greg locke the whole time the team is
trying to get the [ __ ] out of there he's
like how the [ __ ] did i get here what
kind of punishment was this
well it's it's insanity but it reminds
me of a video we watched um
a while ago and i if i can find it here
do you remember the video we watched on
alex jones which is like the demon the
devil will suck out your soul
and it's coming for you you dirty demon
democrats
let's go back to the news
like that's the video that it reminds me
of like these people are competing
for the nuttiest squirrel turd that they
possibly can find they possibly can be
this is insane insanity
insanity that they keep oh my god
competing
for the world's nuttiest squirrel turd
we have bone end of the week maybe we
should have like squirrel turd of the
week um a pole on top of it i don't know
maybe maybe that's the case dude i
it
i'm telling you man you know i used to
used to think they were crazy
well and now we're literally seeing them
nuts you know
these ball tanning [ __ ]
speaking of another ball tandem
[ __ ] this guy needs to tan his
balls if he's not already uh speaking of
speaking of people who stoke racism oh
he's talking about fake accent man yeah
the [ __ ] this weirdo
he's got this word that he loves he
loves the word woke like he [ __ ]
loves the word woke gabe
first and woke up
you mother wokers
like what in the [ __ ] is this guy who is
this guy i don't know why but i i really
love dude
again this white nut sack here i really
believe that it is it not not just for
his manhood but for
prosperity he should tan his nets
because i'm sure can you see how white
this guy is i mean he's whiter than
jordan peterson
yeah
yeah assaulting cracker [ __ ] he
needs a tan as nuts i'm sure he does
let's listen to mr woke here mr woker
let's listen and the second group that
he has running this show there's some
overlap
i would describe as the um
here we go
the the crunchy granoma types
who like to attend gender reveal parties
i mean they're very very woke
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] crunchy wait a second
oh my god what
crunchy granola types that attend gender
reveal parties what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] does that even mean
can you can you decipher this for me
yeah yeah
yeah it's on duckduckgo or google where
we can figure this out crunchy granola
types right are he's talking about like
uh
[ __ ]
not hippies but they're like people who
are like people who live in communes
type things yeah kind of like that when
you're like oh they're grungy they're
canola you know whatever they're like uh
kind of one with the [ __ ]
the earth how do i get dirty they got
dirt underneath their fingers they're
just like you know yeah commune they're
kind of you know uh
they're you know
it's like i don't know exactly know how
to ex explain it they don't like they
don't take bads on a regular basis yeah
yeah they might not shave their armpits
they might not take baths they might
recycle clothes reuse them they might do
whatever you want you know whatever
right right i mean if you if you want to
smell like you smell yeah more power to
you you just may not have as many people
around so that's what he's saying so so
he's saying people who are crunchy are
woke or is he saying
woke people are crunchy that attend
gender reveal parties i'm not sure
basically saying that you know it's a
you know these vegans these like
vegetarian people these green peas
environmental anti-war [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah now i remember i remember the last
time he went on this diet drive he was
talking about salad eaters they right
exactly exactly
so that's what he's saying here is he's
saying that these people who are crunchy
granola types are going to these gender
reveal parties and he's trying to dig
into people who are like pro-environment
you know who are vegan you know or
vegetarian or anti-war whatever it might
be that's basically like anti what he is
you know right
um are are they want to throw these
revealed parties
which
no he's talking about revealed parties
like like like you're someone's like uh
if you're pro-life out there i guess a
woman chooses to carry the baby to term
and you're like having a party to reveal
the gender of the baby that she's caring
is that what you're talking about
exactly how is that woke i mean i'm
against gender reveal parties for a
completely different reason but right
yeah yeah i mean like here in california
we've had people who have thrown gender
reveal parties and have started fires
which obviously are terrible i don't
think gender reveal parties should be
what they are and i think they're right
over
no one no one cares as much as you do
right when you go onto twitter or
instagram
and you do this thing no one [ __ ]
cares right right it cares right it's
great that you're having a kid right
it's great that whatever the gender is
but at the end of the day like how much
time and effort are you spending to do
something that reveals the color of what
the baby is now the other thing he could
be talking about is that you know he
could be taking a dig at someone who
later in life
oh comes out and says
i'm no longer male or i'm no longer
female and i've transitioned or
something like that so it's so that's
what i think he's actually like
i think that's what he's definitely
going after he's not going after someone
who like
biologically right the baby reviews
right right exactly well see because i i
actually the other reason why i i'm not
excited about gender reveal parties is
because
i i think it's just a way for someone to
get more [ __ ] gifts here's
yeah you have the baby shower and then
you have diaper parties and then you
gotta have the j and they they invite
you to all three and they have a [ __ ]
gift list for all three like you sons of
[ __ ] like i'll get you a pack of
diapers and i'll get you a gift but damn
we gotta have so many parties for just
to you know your kids it's important
there are two reasons you have these
parties one
or i guess three reasons one is because
you're an attention uh seeking person
and you just want people to come and be
like
i'm so excited that's great you could do
that in a postcard i don't [ __ ] care
the second is because you want to use it
as an excuse for all the adults to drink
and do whatever right because like oh my
god i need to take all the stress off i
need a drink that's fine you can throw a
completely different party or a
get-together or a [ __ ] dinner party
if you want and the third
is that you're trying to bring more
attention to something and get more
gifts for something because you're like
oh you know what i don't want to pay for
this i want all my friends to pay for it
which is fine you know do what you want
but if you want a registry you don't
have to throw a [ __ ] party for it
right right i so i'm i'm
i'm with the white nutsac here that the
baby reg gender reveal parties the hell
with those mother wokers and i don't
understand how it's woke though i really
don't get how it's woke i understand
that like i guess because you now know
something that you didn't know before
that's why it's woke is that is that the
case i don't know you know crunchy
granola type you know later in life
gender reveal parties is what he's
coming after trans people and he's
coming after people who are anti
who are basically who are liberal like
he's trying to like a blanket he's
trying to be like oh the blue-haired
liberal that is who he's attacking right
now right he's not attacking just like
any you know
you know john doe and jane doe he's he's
attacking the blue haired liberal
persona that republicans love to bash
because that has become the poster child
as their villain they're like i hate
this person they're the ones that are
ruining this country they're trying to
make it socialist you know god forbid
this person cares for another actual
life being or living being a human being
that you actually don't care for that
you'd rather throw this person on the
street and this person's like actually
i'm not christian i'm an atheist but i
share christian values which means that
i'm gonna care for my neighbor and put
shelter over their head and put food in
front of them so they can eat make sure
they have the resources to live and
raise another human being
republicans meanwhile i'm like that's
[ __ ] woke no one [ __ ] does that
you mother wokers you might be like
jesus did that like jesus no we didn't
he never did that jesus that mother woke
her jesus christ that mother woke her
the
the the reality that christians actually
live in
is in an old testament mindset
what you you mean greg locke rick like
all that [ __ ] he was saying is blasphemy
to the to the new testament is that what
you're saying
yeah pretty much i mean i mean you guys
obviously like exodus and yeah you've
got like uh you know revelations and all
that stuff but i'm saying like these
people live by a one zero black white
binary world and it's very much old
testament where that's the only potent
and he's [ __ ] fire breathing and
doing this [ __ ] that the reason why the
reason why is because that's the only
thing that fits their narrative that's
the only thing that fits their narrative
to be to be to be anti-child to be to be
pro starver to be anti-woman to be to be
uh pro
i want to push my religion on you
and i want to control you i've got a
special video for you kathy points out
and reminds us here uh and thank you mj
for your super chat too i hope i don't
miss midas robin's video um we're not
going to miss midas robin we're going to
let midas robin take us out she went to
a rally and she sent me a video on tick
tock so we're going to switch over gabe
from tweety tweets and the trendy trends
to the tiki talks here um so everyone i
actually there's a there's a comment
that uh that robin sent and i wanted to
read it
um that kind of leads up to her at the
rally here
okay um
i just gotta find it i should have
started i knew i should have started i'm
so sorry no that's okay because uh
everyone go follow
robin on twitter and on tick tock um
this is a great video here we go i'm
gonna
so
ramen said to to us
uh you two and the midas touch network
are the reason i had the courage to
attend the rallies of the weekend the
courage to speak came from you all so i
just want to say
thank you so much we really appreciate
this
um and i just kind of wanted to set this
up for for midas robin here actually you
know on the street speaking out at the
rally
and and not just not just in the tweets
but in the streets you're practicing
your first amendment right you're
protecting women's rights um you're
being pro-democracy and robin
you're always always welcome here in the
[ __ ] fam and let's listen to
uh minus robin at the rally before we
before we go
that is what this is body autonomy
our lgbtq people
[Music]
they will come after our right to vote
because they think that women are stupid
and we don't have a voice
we have got to pay attention to
everybody that we put into office we
have to follow what they are passing and
what they are fighting against we have
to see who's fighting for our rights and
who's just [ __ ]
rhetoric crap that means nothing to
anybody
you have to turn off fox news
there's no news on that channel
i'm sorry fox entertainment they've been
to court they argue that nobody will
believe tucker carlson because everybody
knows that tucker carlsbad
[Applause]
i can go on and on about a million
things but the bottom line is yes we
have lived in a country that we thought
all of our rights were protected yes the
democratic party has our back no they
haven't fought hard enough through the
years and they've allowed the gop to
come in swoop in and brainwash and
poison over 50 percent of the people
that vote
and because of that
when you have angry people who think the
government is against you living in a
completely red district where they
control who gets what money when they
control how much money you can make
before you can qualify for food stamps
or anything that you need the republican
party make it impossible to gather those
resources the democratic party gives it
to you every single time
the gop and senate has vowed to block
every single solitary thing that biden's
administration puts up it doesn't matter
if it was fighting any democrat they
would block it they have been blocking
it
so you're out here to fight for our body
and our rights
fight for all our
fight for the rights of the people in
florida fight for the low income people
who need our help the most
i am a mother of seven
children
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you bye this robin thank you very
much for taking us out of the show today
thank you for joining us audience
go follow minus robin on twitter her
handle is in the chat here that gave me
chills that was pretty cool pretty
[ __ ] cool keep going keep getting in
the streets keep with the tweets
because we will be surfing them every
single weekday monday through friday
right here on the donate michaels
podcast
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific and
gabe until tomorrow at that time
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events in political news no
rules no boundaries i think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking